get this i hate your picture night not  to families in winnipeg brought together  by a moment of kindness it all started  last week with seven year old Alex della  Lloyd who has leukemia she caught the  attention of the winnipeg jets with this  poster chemo by day jets by night the  team invited her back on sunday that's  when this happened alex went to check  out a signed hockey stick a young boy  had won several rows down but the boy  nine-year-old keaton hammond followed  her back and gave her the stick right  away at my instinct knew I have to give  it to Alex I felt bad for her that she  had cancer and I wanted to give her a  little support and of course she thanked  him back right away tonight as they  reunited to go to another jets game  together Keaton was given another stick  as a thanks for his generosity